[Music]
those are quite bleep people a buddy set
on the French Mediterranean coast no
wonder this Harbor town is known as
Little Venice
George Poisson one of the best-known
chanson singers in France used to live
here
his music is part of the fabric of life
in set just like the snack the city's
famous for the Giulietta cafe is one
place you'll find the hearty pastry
called TL it's sold as a small
between-meal snack or as a meal Cedric
Anna homo is the chef
[Music]
his ideas that he I said to Barney tl is
originally from Italy immigrants brought
it here it was originally a meal for
peasants it was filling the cheap the
TLM said is tomato sauce and seafood
wrapped in a pastry tada I've been up a
day what I say OCW legitimate Center
said tweak won't reveal his exact recipe
but he hasn't changed the main
ingredients for decades a simple dough
made from water flour and salt a tomato
sauce with spices and diced octopus our
squid from the Mediterranean all covered
with another layer of dough the
consistency of the dough after baking is
not the same everywhere it has two
different flavors here in the middle it
stays soft because of the sauce but the
edges are crispy you Chris Young who
leper team Dario
said leek opened his shop two years ago
his employees follow his grandmother's
TL recipe down to the letter she's
linked ababa do determinate yeah I can't
say exactly what's in the TL as far as I
know it's tomatoes and squid it's a
small delicacy and very typical of the
region and very tasty
we might ill I'm gonna don't look what
we the specialty of the house a tiara
made with eggplant and Parmesan cheese
[Music]